[Music]
the ethical substance kept the
antithesis confined within it simply
unitary consciousness and preserve this
consciousness in an immediate unity with
its essence essence has therefore the
simple determinants of mere being for
consciousness which is directed
immediately in comment it is the essence
in the form of custom consciousness
neither thinks of itself as this
particular exclusive self nor have
substance the significance of an
existence excluded from it with which it
would have to become United only by
alienating itself from itself and at the
same time producing the substance itself
but the spirit itself is an absolutely
discrete unit has its content
confronting it as an equally hard
unyielding reality and here the world
has the character of being something
external the negative of self
consciousness this world is however a
spiritual entity it is itself the inter
fusion of being an individuality this
its existence is the work of self
consciousness but it is also an alien
reality already present and given a
reality which has a being of its own and
in which it does not recognize itself
this real world is the external essence
of the free content of legal right but
this external world which the Lord of
the world with legal right it takes to
himself is not merely this elemental
being confronting the self is something
contingently given on the contrary it is
his work but not on the positive rather
in a negative sense it attains its
existence through self consciousness is
own externalization and separation of
itself from its essence which in the
ruin and devastation which prevail in
the world of legal right seems to
inflict on self consciousness from
without the violence of the liberated
elements these by themselves are sheer
ruin and devastation and the dissolution
of themselves this dissolution however
the
negative nature there is just the self
it is their subject their activity and
their process but this activity and
process whereby the substance becomes
actual is the alienation of the
personality for the self that has an
absolute significance in its immediate
existence that is without having
alienated itself from itself is without
substance and is the plaything of those
raging elements in substance therefore
is if externalization and the external
ization is the substance that is the
spiritual powers ordering themselves
into a world and thereby preserving
themselves
in paragraph 484 we are now entering a
new section of this this massive spirit
portion of the work and if this new
intermediate section is quite long it's
also organized a little bit differently
than some of the preceding sections have
been you notice that in this we're going
to have three main portions but the
portions are broken up in different ways
and the third portion is just just one
long sequence so this entire section is
called self alienated spirit Vic and
from data guys and and culture this this
word building that Hegel uses that we
devoted a good deal of discussion to
much earlier on in the work when he was
talking about this in the preface I'm
not going to spend a lot of time talking
about building right now in part because
we're going to spend so much time going
through it as we make our way through
this section but I do want to point out
that that building has a more active
connotation than what we typically
associate with culture we look at
culture primarily in terms of something
that a person has or in terms of the
material culture the things that embody
a cultural perspective or embody you
know the sort of thing that an
ethnologist would study and building
extends all the way into education so
that that's enough to say about that
Hegel is talking here in the very first
paragraph about this this transition and
he references back to the the previous
development and paragraphs particularly
those in the legal standing section that
we just made our way through but he
begins from what might seem like a
strange starting point he talks about
the ethical substance keeping this
antithesis this kind
tradition confined within a simply
unitary consciousness and then he says
it preserved this consciousness and
immediate unity with its essence essence
has therefore simple determinate as a
beer mere being for consciousness which
is directly immediately upon it and is
the essence in the form of custom so
when we say this it sounds like well
that isn't that like a reversion back to
previous stages and you know it's worth
considering and keeping in mind that
Hegel does intend this dialectic to be
kind of you know jumping forward and
then sometimes falling back a bit and
moving forward
falling back the other thing to keep in
mind is that we're moving historically
from the essentially the ancient period
you know which which we've sort of
traversed in the Greek city-state in the
Roman city state as far as Hegel is
interpreting them into things like world
empires you know we you know we can
think of the Roman Empire in particular
but we might also think about the Greek
successor states that are coming after
the conquest of Alexander of Macedon and
other similar developments that are
taking place perhaps you know we can
think of the Persian Empire or other
empires that that are arising in
antiquity in this period of culture we
have an endpoint which is the
Enlightenment and not just the
Enlightenment but also the revolution
and freedom and the terror where are we
starting from where we're really
starting from the Middle Ages and moving
our way
progressively through this at least
that's how Hegel is telling the story so
he tells us here that consciousness
neither thinks of itself of this
particular exclusive self nor has
substance the significance of an
existence excluded from it with which it
would have to become United only by
alienating itself from itself and at the
same time producing the substance itself
so that sounds pretty
would but that sounds very different
than what we Traverse particularly like
I said in the last section of legal
right or legal standing so he goes on
and he says but the spirit whose self is
an absolutely discrete unit what what is
that that is the spirit that is the
individual of legal right and so we're
talking about the self-consciousness of
legal right and its relationship to a
world world which is going to be opposed
to it and the question is what is its
relationship with this this world and as
it turned out the relationship is going
to be a lot more complicated than at
first appears so he tells us it has its
content confronting it as an equally
hard unyielding reality here the world
is the character being something
external the negative of
self-consciousness so the object of
self-consciousness in this case is the
world against which it defines itself as
an individual and the world resists it
the world tells it no the world you know
maybe even Rob's it of things and it
experiences the world in an antagonistic
way you could say now he goes on into
this world of the spiritual entity it is
itself nice phrase here the inter fusion
of being and individuality so the world
is where something very important is
taking place and he tells us that this
existence is actually the work of self
consciousness so self consciousness is
laboring under a kind of illusion at
this point in taking the world merely as
a given when really this world that
exists is in part the work of self
consciousness it is you might say the
product of self consciousness and
self-consciousness is doing something
interesting
to itself in this process you notice
they've got these three terms here laid
out and we'll come back to the text in a
moment but I really want to talk about
these three terms two of which we're
going to see coming up over and over and
over again in the text and and coming up
in important ways first one is an femdom
we translate this as alienation or
estrangement and Fremd it says is the
this you know spirit alienated from
itself friend you know in this case and
then at the end of course that you see
in each edge implies a kind of
distancing right the friend 'm means
something that's alien to it something
that is other something that is
different and so this is an other ring
of itself it is it is losing its own
grasp on its identity you could say or
it's it's certainty of itself it feels
alienated when we talked about feeling
alienated or being alienated we mean
that we have lost a part of ourself then
there's also this other very important
term and also wrong right
externalization again very important
within the Hegelian dialectic because we
know that no idea really matters unless
it can be externalized can be made via
quick actual real can be brought out
into the world and self-consciousness is
doing precisely that but it's also
losing part of itself in externalizing
itself in this way and then Hegel in
this this passage is also going to talk
about separation and Vaes on right so
we've got these three ents here and this
is what self-consciousness is doing to
itself now it takes it takes its
experience is coming from the world
doing that to it but really it is also
involved in doing these things to itself
so he goes on and he says
if the world is also an alien reality
present and given a reality has a being
of its own and in which self
consciousness does not recognize it so
now he characterized this world in
several different ways it is on the one
hand he says the world of legal right
the world that has been constituted in
the stage of legal right everybody's got
their peace everybody is a person in
this nobody really matters more than
anyone else except of course for the
Lord of the world somebody has to make
all of this order work right and so he
says the the external world which the
lord of the world of legal right takes
to himself is not nearly this elemental
being confronting the self of something
continually given that came to be what
the lord of the world was this guy
happens to be in charge and so that
lucky bastard he has all the authority
and gets to enjoy the world and we're
stuck over here dealing with his
arbitrariness and his caprices it seems
very contingent right Hegel here we'll
talk about elemental being something
else he's going to hit on a little bit
later in the next section and he says
that here we go it's not merely this
elemental being confronting the self is
something continually given on the
contrary it is his work whose work
self-consciousness is work but in not in
a positive rather than a negative sense
here's where we get the the other ends
coming in it obtains its existence
through self-consciousness his own
externalization and separation of itself
from its essence which in the ruin and
devastation which prevail in the world
of legal right without what let's pause
for a moment why is he talking about
ruin and devastation in the world of
legal right remember back to just a few
paragraphs earlier we're in the world of
legal right something like the movement
that took place in the self
consciousness subsection of sky
Estes ISM occurred skepticism turns not
only against any positivity in the world
it also turns against itself and an
admitted sown contingency and the very
contingency of contingency there is a
kind of ruin a kind of evacuation of
meaningfulness that takes place and
that's happening here in in this world
and in self consciousness was own
separation from itself it's own
externalization its own alienation from
itself so he says that this appears to
inflict on self-consciousness things
from without the violence of the
liberated element the the guys who are
in charge right but he says these by
themselves are sheer ruin and
devastation and the dissolution of
themselves but this is just itself it is
their subject their activity and their
process so Hegel says we can actually
get something out of this here this
activity in process is the process by
which the substance becomes actual but
it takes place through the alienation of
the personality so he says the stuff
that has an absolute significance and
its immediate existence without having
alienated itself from itself is without
substance at this point in time
alienation it which feels like a bad
thing actually turns out to be something
good because it opens the door to
development that is going to be taking
place through this entire movement of
culture so now we have to see where all
of this is is going and how we're going
to have these spiritual powers ordering
themselves into a world thereby
preserving themselves rather than just
the arbitrariness of everybody is equal
except for this guy whose most equal
substance is in this way spirit the
self-conscious unity and itself in
essence each has for the other the
significance of alienation spirit is the
consciousness of an objective real world
freely existing on its own account but
this consciousness is confronted by the
unity of the self and essence actual
consciousness by pure consciousness on
the one side actual self consciousness
truth externalization passes over into
the actual world and the latter back
into actual self consciousness on the
other side the same actuality will
person and objectivity is superseded
they are cure Li universal this their
alienation as pure consciousness or
essence the present actual world has its
antithesis directly in its beyond which
is both the thinking of it and its
thought form just as a beyond as in the
present world its actuality but in
actuality alienated from it
many readers of Hegel quite
understandably when they're looking at
this book the phenomenology find the
passages within it incredibly abstract
and they struggle to figure out okay
what is what is exactly going on here
and I think that paragraph 485 it may
not be the most abstract passage in the
in the work as a whole but it certainly
gives many of them a run for their money
so the question that we want to ask is
what is going on in this this passage in
this paragraph 45 what is he talking
about and I think that although a lot of
commentators really have liked this
phrase that he begins with substance
becoming spirit I wouldn't worry so much
about that at this point in time I would
pay much closer attention to this
discussion of the relation between
actual consciousness and pure
consciousness not least because of where
we are ultimately going to be going and
not not ultimately but actually fairly
shortly in the next few sections so he
does save substance in this way spirit
the self conscious unity of the self in
essence this is a formulation that's
going to show up here a little bit later
under self under pure consciousness as
opposed to actual consciousness he says
each has for the other the significance
of alienation now what is the each what
is the having for the other is it
substance and spirit that are that are
having this is it's supposed to be self
and essence we're going to have to see
how this plays out so he says spirits is
the consciousness of an objective real
world freely existing on its own account
now that's spirit at this point right it
is also spirit earlier on I mean in the
consciousness action clearly we're being
confronted with at least with an object
by the end of fourth in the
understanding we really are dealing with
worlds
the the world of self-consciousness is a
world of others and then we have the
world of reason once again turning at
first observation of nature and then
very quickly to observation of the human
being and then through looking at
practical reason human action so anyway
he says it's a consciousness of an
objective real world freely exist
against on account but this
consciousness is confronted again he
says by the unity of self and essence
and now here he tells us that this
confrontation is between actual
consciousness you know vir click at the
horse side and pure consciousness line
of Woodside so what is this this pure
consciousness are we sort of taking a
transcendental turn at this point no not
not exactly we're not doing metaphysics
of conscience Bend here as a matter of
fact what we're going to be launching
into you've talked about it beyond we're
going to be talking about something that
replicates some of the movements of the
unhappy consciousness if you remember
consciousness self consciousness in that
case was casting something that it
alienated from itself out there as the
divine the absolute the eternal the
unchanging and it was dealing with its
own actual consciousness which was sort
of not quite so good
by comparison something that it was not
happy with here we're going to be moving
past the unhappy consciousness and
ultimately into the realm of faith which
is not yet the same thing for Hegel as
religion which is a later section but
does have a similar beyond to it as well
so he goes on and he tells us actual
self consciousness through its
externalization passes over into the
actual world this is part of what we're
going to be charted out
the paragraphs that are yet to come
these dynamics of how actual
consciousness does externalize itself in
the actual world and then he says in the
latter back into actual
self-consciousness the world goes back
into self consciousness there's there's
a dynamic interplay between the two of
them but he says on the other side this
same actuality is superseded right when
we're talking about the other side we
mean that of pure consciousness the
actual consciousness is sublated is
superseded it is alcohol bin' and this
is in fact it's alienation he says they
are purely universal person and
objectivity their alienation is pure
consciousness or essence and you know
this is if we want to make this a little
bit more concrete think about when you
learn now this is not what Hegel saying
here but think about when you learn that
the essence of you is to be a rational
mortal animal if we want to use you know
boethius's formulation right or a
rational animal we lose
Aristotle's formulation that rational
you forget the animal part right that's
not so so worrisome here but that
rational is universal
what does it mean for you to be rational
well doesn't it end up meaning to be
rational more or less in the same way as
everybody else is rational but then how
is it you how is it your own you know it
seems like the more that you behave
rationally the more that you conform to
your essence the less it's really you so
does that mean that you should behave
irrationally well then you would you
know in a certain sense be taking
yourself further away from the essence
and further away from the purity of
consciousness and you'd be alienated in
a different way as well so it seems like
alienation is
is almost inevitable at this point so he
goes on and he says this their
alienation is pure consciousness or
essence the present actual world has its
antithesis directly in Beyond which is
both the thinking of it and its thought
form just as the Beyond has in the
present world its actuality but now
notice what he says in actuality
alienated from it both sides need each
other the Beyond requires in order to be
instantiated actuality but that
actuality seems like its meaning is is
ebbing away from it and the more that it
comes to understand itself and its
essence the more it is superseded the
more it becomes alienated from itself
you